this is an exam question given this year
to high school students in turkey
a project team consists of 100 people
every member is appointed to an equal
number of projects
no two people are appointed to the exact
same projects the situation cannot be
achieved if every member is appointed to
three projects but can be achieved if
every member is appointed to four
projects
so how many projects does the team have
6 7 8 9 or 10. have a think i'll answer
in a minute but first let's take a step
back and think about how we got here
this question is from an exam paper
called ayt which is one of two papers
given to high school students in turkey
who wish to gain entrance to university
it is set by over 2.5 million students
per year and contains questions about
turkish language social science
mathematics and science and as is a
common theme with exams like this from
around the world this exam can really be
a make or break moment in the lives of
young people
turkey has its own breed of cram schools
and i've received plenty of comments
from turkish students about this exam
and how it has impacted their life
here's one that says of the more than
two million people who take it every
year that only a few rank high enough to
get into the best universities it is
considered as an only chance at a good
future by everyone
most people start studying two years
before the exam and in the last year
people can study up to 10 to 15 plus
hours a day
you'd better hope that you're a good
all-rounder because the exam paper
combines all of the different subjects
together and you have 180 minutes to
answer
166 questions
this math question i showed was number
15 on the 2021 paper and was
particularly controversial because of
its difficulty a similar type of problem
appeared on the turkish mathematical
olympiad so students were left wondering
why an olympiad level question was given
to everyone including those who have no
intention to major in math
to understand it i want to talk about
something called the pigeonhole
principle
in mathematics the pigeonhole principle
states that if n items are put into m
containers with n being greater than m
then at least one container must contain
more than one item so over here if we
have 10 pigeons dispersed within nine
pigeon holes
then since 10 is greater than 9 then
there will be at least one pigeonhole
that has more than one pigeon and up
here we can see this one has two pigeons
in it honestly a little too obvious a
little too basic to seem useful but
actually we can use it to solve our
problem
our problem is one of finding the
containers
our items n
is 100 people
and these hundred people are being
dispersed across the containers but our
containers are not the projects
our containers are the unique sets of
projects that each person is appointed
to
so if x is the total number of projects
then the set of all projects goes from
p1 up to px
if everyone is appointed to three
projects then the containers would
represent each unique combination of
three projects
the first container might have p1 p2 p3
the next one p1 p2 p4
then p1 p2 p5 and so on until we've had
every unique combination
the question requires that no two people
are appointed to the exact same projects
which would be two people or i guess we
can use turkeys in one container
but we also know from the question that
for three projects each the situation
doesn't work out so actually we are
going to have at least one container
with more than one person in it so let's
find out when that happens
according to the pigeonhole principle
it's when n is greater than m so when we
have more people or turkeys than we do
containers we know that we have 100
people so if the number of containers is
anything less than 100 we're going to
have some double ups but how do we find
the number of containers how do we find
the unique combinations of three
projects well we can use the
combinations formula
in choose r also can be written like
this
so we want x choose 3 to be less than
100 we know we're going to have some
double ups
our options for x are 6 7 8 9 or 10 and
of these 10 choose 3 is the only one
that's not less than 100 so it can be
ruled out as a possible answer
now let's see about four projects each
we know that this time it will all work
out and there will be no double ups
our containers are all the unique
combinations of four projects and the
number of containers is given by x
choose four
and this time we want that value to be
more than or equal to a hundred
six seven and eight choose four all give
values less than a hundred so they are
ruled out as possible options
and the only remaining option for x that
satisfies both criteria is nine
so we can say that the correct answer
here is d
here's that question as it was
originally presented in turkish we can
look through and see some of the other
questions
for this one you have p of x a fourth
degree polynomial you're given all the
conditions you need to know about p and
then asked to find what is p at four in
17 you're asked to find the limit of a
rather nasty function without using a
calculator moving on to some physics
this question here asks us about the
relationship between the velocities of
three different paths of the golf ball
if we go back to maths for a second we
can find this question here which can be
translated into english to say that m
and n are positive integers
the g c d of m and n plus the lcm of m
and n is 289
m plus n is not equal to 289
so find the total m plus n
this one is near the start of the paper
and seems like it might be a bit easier
but actually it can be a bit tricky to
help us understand this one i'm going to
turn to brilliant who have sponsored
this section of the video we have this
situation that hot dogs are sold in
packages of 10 while the buns are sold
in packages of 8. suppose you want to
buy exactly the same number of hot dogs
and buns what is the minimum amount you
will need to buy
this is us having to find the lowest
common multiple
the lcm
these are the multiples of 10
these are the multiples of 8 and the
lowest common one is 40.
next question if we want to reduce the
fraction 24 over 30 to lowest terms
what number should you divide the
numerator and denominator by
the answer is 6 and that is our gcd the
greatest common divisor these are all
the numbers 24 can be divided by these
are all the numbers that 30 can be
divided by and the greatest common one
is six
going back to our question let's just
call the gcd of m and n some value x
that would mean m can be written as x
times some value a
and n would be x times some value b
now a and b are relatively prime there's
no common factor between them and
nothing further that you could divide
them both by
that would mean that the lowest common
multiple of m and n
is x times a times b
so our equation up here becomes x plus x
times a b
is 289
we can rewrite that as x times one plus
a b
here are the table of possible values
that would make this true
we can already rule out this second
option because if one plus a b was equal
to one then a b would have to be equal
to zero and we know that's not true
because m and n are positive integers so
we can try the first option x is one and
one plus a b is two eight nine so a b is
two eight eight being able to factorize
this into its prime factors and
therefore being able to work out what
possible factors it has is a crunch
point for this question but in this
little table here i've put the two
options for either a or b looking at the
total m plus n for the first option we
would end up with one plus two eight
eight which is two eight nine however
the question says that that is not
allowed so this is not a possible option
trying the next option we have 32 plus 9
which is 41. that's probably the right
answer but we still had one option to
try over here which is when x and 1 plus
a b both equal to 17 because 17 squared
is 2 8 9. to get a times b equal to 16 1
has to be 1 and the other has to be 16.
you might think that 2 and 8 are also
options but if you remember a and b are
relatively prime and 2 and 8 have a
common factor of 2 so aren't relatively
prime this option also ends up giving us
that m plus n is 289 which we can't have
so the correct answer to this question
is indeed 41.
you can do more lcm and gcd problems on
brilliant head to brilliant.org tippies
to try for yourself
thanks brilliant for supporting this
video and also thanks to my patreon
supporters a special shout out to
today's patreon cat of the day ember
[Music]
you